so some some claim that our ruling in
favor of religious liberty and free
speech a ruling in favor of masterpiece
cake shop and Jack Phillips that will
destroy all sorts of anti-discrimination
legislation in the country but there is
no evidence for that as the cake shops
lawyers Phillips himself have made clear
the custom cake is an artistic piece
that clearly comes along with free
artistic and philosophical expression
that's why they're so expensive
that's why the bakery is called a
masterpiece cake shop it's not called
commodity cake shop or food cake shop or
regular old $10 gig job it's a
masterpiece it involves artistic
expression by the way it is also ironic
that the left which is degraded and
deconstructed art so much that now you
know a tricycle on top of a newspaper is
art or a giant block in a park or a
smear of colour on a wall that sort of
thing now those people are telling us
that confections delicately crafted to
be exhibited at the centerpiece of
wedding ceremonies masterpieces those
are not art but that is neither here nor
there the point is that it isn't
discrimination it isn't that the artist
can choose which customers he will serve
if hopefully the Supreme Court rules in
favor of religious liberty here it's not
that the the artist can say I'm gonna
sell to you but not sell to you the
artist has to sell cakes to everybody as
he repeatedly offered to do in this case
the portrait photographer has to take
photos of everybody the painter has to
paint paintings of everybody but these
artists don't need to convey ideas with
which they disagree a Christian painter
the Christian painter is not required by
law to paint an image of Satan's
stomping on the head of Christ a
Christian photographer is not required
by law or the Constitution to recreate
the piss Christ consider the reverse
actually to drive the point home with
not-so-subtle a brush there's an
evangelical pastor named Joshua
Fierstein I think he called an a
florida-based bakery that calls itself
LGBT friendly he called it up and
ordered a cake decorated with the phrase
quote we do not support gay marriage now
as you might expect it as Fierstein
expected the bakery hung up that's
entirely their right they didn't want to
express that idea with their art they
have every right
moral and constitutional to refuse to
express certain ideas in art
anti-discrimination laws entitle you to
an artist's products but not to their
creativity the left now insists on this
schizophrenic argument freedom of choice
and consent are the essential
prerequisites a modern life until you
contradict their ever-changing wertha
Doxie because hashtag me to only matters
until hashtag love wins